[Music]
prince andrew yeah
totally losing best prince around what's
what's that number one fan
but
yeah
like it's a sports team that you know
yes my boy it's my dog
[Music]
he's your favorite epstein character
he's my favorite
out of all the characters he can choose
he's your favorite one he fascinates me
the most i've talked about this so many
times but his interview
of what i think it was 60 minutes when
he was sweating bro he's his ties all
[ __ ] up and he's just like yeah
virginia dufresne never seen that [ __ ]
in my life never seen her ever you know
and it's just like it's so crazy he's
like you
oh god he's like so nervous so nervous
so he he loses all of his military
titles and the use of his royal highness
took him [ __ ] long enough long enough
yeah because he has finally formally
entered a civil sex lawsuit oh damn dude
they really showed him didn't he
you think he's going to get off
it's hard to say but the duke of york's
military titles and royal patronages
have been returned to the queen oh no
they're up for grabs you should get them
go for them i'll take it prince andrew
who's 61 will also stop using the style
his royal highness in an official
capacity and it comes as he faces a u.s
civil action over sexual assault
allegations claims and uh source close
to the duke said he would continue to
defend himself against the case by
virginia jeffrey jupiter dufresne i
don't know i think i think it's due yeah
i don't know it says jeffrey
g-i-u-f-f-r-e
jeffrey jeffrey jeffrey epstein
absolutely didn't kill him
[Laughter]
he's prince andrew
the source insisted the judges ruling on
wednesday that the civil action could
proceed
um
you got killed it's face-off too
oh dude
dude jeffrey face-off he's some he's
hiding something it's john travolta
instead holy [ __ ]
that's the best spin and who's john
travolta nicholas
cage in conair the math writes itself oh
my god
but uh buckingham palace said in a
statement with the queen's approval and
agreement the duke of york's military
affiliations and royal patronages have
been returned to the queen the duke of
york will continue not to undertake any
public duties and is defending this case
as a private citizen oh my god
all of prince andrew's roles have been
returned to the queen with immediate
effect and will be redistributed to
other members of the royal family you
could
redistribute a role what was his
official role what did he the duke of
[ __ ] nothing who gives the [ __ ] what
he does so he had a bunch of like uk
military titles um for example like
honorary air
none
commodore
these titles mean anything that sounds
like an air butler or something yeah
dude haircut that's like different like
being sergeant-at-arms of your class
like
asb he pours drinks in the air
what if he's afraid of heights he's
never good bro
this is all attached to
the the title the royal title so he's
the son of the queen son of the queen
son of a [ __ ] see what a piece of [ __ ]
this guy is he's this he's queen
elizabeth's son
yeah see this means you can't have a
prince and then have him do stuff
because he's going to go out and find a
very famous
rich influencer who likes to [ __ ] kids
and do it with him this is what happens
you gotta stay humble bro you don't say
humble that's what happens when you
don't stay humble you start [ __ ] kids
with rich people humility and pedophilia
you saw they're gonna release all the
names
they are this is what they said we'll
find out they said i think if they said
it's up to the judges or something yeah
they wanna do it or not i'm like why is
it up to them for i think it's for
safety because they have to they
probably have to do their investigation
and to gather all the evidence without
people tampering they have to do it
secretly because then people like us
will be like yo did you hear yeah and
then you'll hear some cunan because the
press is irresponsible as [ __ ]
the anti
you know epstein coalition well what's
weird is that i mean the written house
case was just all live and they were
recording that but then how come this
can't be recorded i think what they said
was is because it's a federal case or
something like that so it's it's just
they don't
they didn't want uh evidence tampering
that's what their main reasoning was i
would guess my easy answer guess is that
everyone involved is incredibly powerful
yeah and so they can't cause a [ __ ]
storm from the top yeah that was their
official uh reasoning so it says here
everybody involved was extremely
powerful and they can't call it
shitstorm
see what he's not telling you is i
actually wrote this article and i've
sabotaged all of you
misinformation yeah it's instead of
shitstorm it's just bollocks blizzard
though
that's regional yeah they're like oh
[ __ ] that was really good do you think
anything's gonna happen to him though
even if he's guilty like even it like i
bet he's getting he could find a good
defense i'm sure some sort of larry h
parker because you know galen now is
they're saying um
how it's it might be a mistrial yeah and
that case could be thrown out all this
[ __ ] i think they're gonna try to claim
that jamie was 17 at the time which
makes it okay apparently according to
like the uk law or something i think
that's what i read oh that's the age of
consent
yeah 17 is age of consent new york yeah
but they were they were at maxwell's
house that time that they were together
something like that new york was that
new york i don't know she had they had a
uh so epstein had a house in new york
and then before the island that was the
that was the hookup spot they would he
would go to the island they had a place
in florida that's where the whole first
case was just one of those territorial
[ __ ] things that you're just like oh
circumstantial you know we were in the
right region international waters yeah
that shit's crazy they went on a
carnival cruise
and and then they just traverse into
international waters where the rules are
just you know cigarettes are five
dollars
you can get milk carton-sized bacardi
bottles for twelve dollars
free [ __ ] man unlimited nacho cheese
free pizza and ice cream nighttime
performance via prince's lawyers had
argued that her case should be dismissed
citing a 2009 deal she signed with
convicted sex offender jeffrey epstein
so that's also what the prince's lawyers
are just like we already dealt with this
you already got paid so why the [ __ ] are
you talking about it's not even we
already dealt with it it's like it was
already dealt with with epstein epstein
paid you on double jeopardy why are you
[ __ ] coming up to us for money you
already got paid yeah but they were
trying to extradite them for a while do
these lawyers ever go home and go like
i'm a [ __ ] scumbag probably
some of them maybe
want to win they just want to win uh i
feel like at that point though it's all
about winning did they say that about
robert kardashian like that's why he
kind of there was all these rumors about
how he felt so much tremendous guilt
after the case because he knew o.j
simpson killed that woman i don't know
but weren't they friends like before
that's why he protected him right but
then also i'm sure as he went through
the case he was like this [ __ ]
did it yeah and he has to pretend and we
gotta ask david trump yeah doesn't every
lawyer kind of know that their client's
guilty or not in the beginning they're
supposed and then it's just really going
through the motions of how to because i
think that gets you more respect if you
[ __ ] get someone off that was
actually guilty doing it for the respect
the respect isn't that more like you
you're way more feared as a powerhouse
if you can do that [ __ ] that's true
forget about justice or you're just good
at your job in a 46-page decision judge
louise kaplan dismissed prince andrew's
contention that the case against him was
legally insufficient and could not go on
to be heard at a future trial and mr
free now 38 filed a civil case in new
york in august 2021 under the state's
child victim act which allows survivors
of childhood sexual abuse to pursue a
case in which otherwise would have been
barred because too much time had passed
it's a good luck yeah it's pretty fire
so in court documents filed as part of
her civil case against prince andrew ms
dufrey said she was the victim of sex
trafficking and abuse by the late
billionaire financier epstein and she
alleged that part of her abuse involved
being loaned out to powerful men
wow
sex with prince andrew when she was 17
and she alleges that duke abused her on
three occasions both in the uk and the
u.s when she was a minor under u.s law
there it is oh
in an interview with bbc news night in
2019 the queen's second son said that he
had no recollection of ever meeting mr
he's like i [ __ ] so many girls i don't
even remember that [ __ ] they showed him
the picture of them together and he goes
never seen her in my life
he's like he's got his arm around her
and stuff like that she's clearly he
looked very happy to be with this this
young woman and it's in a very casual
home too it's like upstairs i saw this
[ __ ] yeah dude this guy's sketch bro he
did it
modern shaggy and even if he did it who
cares bro get rid of it it wasn't me
it wasn't me
he plays that song in the [ __ ]
courtroom as he walks in with [ __ ] it
wasn't me
it wasn't me the [ __ ] big ben starts
playing it now
right when it's midnight it just starts
it playing me
it wasn't me
what are your guys's favorite prince
andrew moments
you guys wanna go around the table or
something i shared mine
what do you guys got your favorite
moment is when he denied ever seeing the
girl that he was right next to
that he was in the picture with that's
where my moment was bro i thought it was
hilarious i thought this guy was genius
well this guy's a [ __ ] crazy he's a
mastermind you're like i honestly i have
to i have to be honest i didn't know
this person was
existed until in this case and why is he
the prince of something see because he's
born family of royalty set him on fire
dude get rid of them this is how it
works dudes head in there you're too
french bro yeah i know
the bourgeoisie over here he's like
let's get chop off yeah dude [ __ ] the
reign of fire or whatever you know like
we like the royal family they we love
the queen the queen's like a cute little
grandma the queen is cool they're
spoiled ass [ __ ] kids they destroyed
my ancestors i have to take a hard step
oh okay okay okay so i have to take i
have to take a heart stamp we gotta
support test and say [ __ ] that i hired a
bunch of your ancestors now right that's
true too was it yeah but it's all
manipulation this is what they do they
exploit all the people of color meghan
markle's married to william harry harry
did they kick him out uh no he left oh
yeah he left because i was about to say
i was like they kicked him out before
you didn't see the oprah interview oh i
think you watched the other one but not
this one yeah i wanna
yeah come on with that i think that
oprah one came out before this one no it
did yeah yeah yeah why did it take him
so long to remove all the [ __ ]
like titles from this guy because i
think the uh civil law uh suit didn't
actually take effect against him yet i
think there were all a bunch of like
allegations the media people trying to
question but it wasn't a full thing they
got rid of what was the other one prince
harry yeah prince harry was just like yo
we're you're racist i'm out yeah and
then they were like
yeah you're right we raised it right
hey good call good call
this one they're like no he didn't touch
anyone like never
[Music]
you